okay but it's only one case it's only
one case I'm going to ask you guys to
prove the other two but I'll start by
drawing the diagrams for you okay if a
is equal to 90 right this is the easy
one remember I said P are the center of
the circles inside the triangle okay if
my corner angle that I'm interested in
is 90 degrees it's actually draw that's
many degrees let's make that a okay and
now I need the other side of triangle
like so where does the center lie in
relation to this train that's up
fantastic it's it's on it's on with what
that's right it's on this a length
little AB and I'm looking for it's the
hypotenuse of this triangle right so I
have a all the way across here right but
because the angle the semicircle it's
also the diameter there's the set up
that's the case two for case three this
Center will not be inside the triangle
and the center will not be on the
triangle where do you think I'm going to
be within a / - single the center put it
there okay it's going to be outside
because look what happens if a is obtuse
like that like that's an acute angle
call that a right look at what's gonna
happen to a little way right it's not
gonna be close enough to the center okay
so there's a little way so I proved it
for you for case one that this is equal
to the diameter of the circumcircle give
it a go if the case - in case three
you'll need slightly different ways to
do it that's why we have different cases
but give it a try and if you think you
have an idea call me ever not have a
look first let me deal with a way not to
prove the case too
okay so let me get another color okay
now is he so he's he's what I've had
suggested to me okay and immediately
it's not that far from the truth but
I'll show you why this method doesn't
work okay so here's what I've had
suggested to me look it's a right angle
triangle right right angle triangle so
if I would sign a right well sine is
opposite on hypotenuse isn't it isn't it
now a it's over here so the opposite
side you can write it as a or is d
because they're the same right so you
could for example you could write it and
it would be what you wanted right that's
the opposite side and then you say
what's opposite on hypotenuse and the
hypotenuse I could write it as Dickey
right and then you swap them around your
life yeah
I'm sorry cool no you're not okay now
let me show you why let me show you why
cuz it does seem kind of instinctive
right I'll tell you why not this
highlights one of the reasons why we had
to move away from triangles specifically
right angle triangles and to the unit
circle in order to define what sine and
cosine mean sine and cosine have no
meaning when applied to 90 degrees in a
right angle triangle it doesn't work now
it almost looks like it works for sine
but you can see when as soon as I go to
cosine you can see how it breaks down
okay because cosine is adjacent on
hypotenuse apparently right but if I'm
here which jacent side do I want because
I got two of them right and it turns out
that not only is it like hard to choose
which one it's hard to choose because
you can't choose either of them because
cos of 90 degrees is in fact zero right
but it doesn't make sense either
triangle okay so sine and cosine you
can't really apply it to the right angle
in a right angle triangle it only works
with the other two okay
so therefore what can we do with this
well well the proof I'm going to show
you all this
says mantra triggers its butt and Aaron
Aaron got it
it is actually mathematically sound is
anyone allergic there's anyone actually
allergic this is bad
it's like okay so now that all dangerous
threats have left the classroom can we
refocus alright well let me show you let
me show you so here's what I'm going to
say forget about this triangle for a
second to give at this triangle for a
second something that you know is true
before you arrive at this is this weave
note we've known this for a while now
right we defined it on the unit circle
and that's what we got okay but this
means that sine 9 equals 1 right sine of
any angle that's also equal to my team
will also be one you agree with that
right any angular take what amount you
can pop in there and I have one it's a
right so I can say sign a was one agree
with that okay so one of the handy
things about one is that one is its own
reciprocal right one is its own
reciprocal so I'm gonna take the
reciprocal left and the reciprocal over
Y and that will give me this you're
happy with that
okay watch I'm gonna multiply both sides
by a because a is just a number it's
just a length right isn't it problem
with that so I'm gonna multiply this
side by a and this side by a right
but a ain't happens to also be equal to
D my god